it's comfortable you'll love it oh i got
this big white phone in my back pocket
not as big as the old one what
it's got the extended battery case what
were you thinking i was thinking your
big zack morris phone uh
also the way you're i knew you would
like these chairs because it's kind of
like sitting on top of a trash bin
sesame street no no you did this i did
this this was in your past
i was this was in my past i watched your
past
i watched a good portion of your past
you say you're an obsessed fan of mine
yeah well you don't understand it i
wanted to be your character so badly
that like it's almost like you're my dad
we've sealed the exits
so let's get this straight
ac slater became my father
right that's right right okay and i
didn't care that he could beat any of
any of them he beat me up ac dinny mario
oh there was a fight there was a fight
there was a fight
no you could be honest it's it's been 20
years
i think
the script says no no no no because you
were a viewer you watched it yeah how
did you feel when you saw that like i'm
your guy yeah you watch that you see him
like land one on me yeah how did you
react
i thought that you took the moral high
road and let him win
so
okay because you knew you'd have a
better chance to kapowski
did you ever kapowski
is your alcohol you know
can i ask you a serious question did i
ever compose
let me ask you
know which tiffan feast do you prefer
save by the bell or 90210 oh
yeah oh that's tough yeah yeah yeah
this is a serious show
you know what there's there's a there's
a period
that yeah i think it's the malibu
beach episodes
like that was that was like that was a
real thing that was a real thing i had
such a crush on her at that point yeah
because up until then i mean it's like
you know you're it's a working
relationship you kind of grew up
together where you did it's you see
these people every day they're like the
kids at school we've been together for
six years but that at that point i was
like wow she's
and then the hormones i was 16. yeah so
the hormones i remember that yeah